let me let me thank the organizers for
the opportunity to speak here and and
also just for putting these events
together it's it's a lot of fun for the
rest of us to come here and you know see
friends and talk mathematics and and and
it's thanks to the hard work that you're
doing behind the scenes and the serious
work so we really appreciate it
I also appreciate that a I think there's
a very broad range of topics in this in
this workshop and I think one thing that
means is that you know I'm going to be
talking about the geometry of matrix and
I'm sure many of you never think about
matrix or about geometry necessarily so
especially to the students if you have
any questions it doesn't matter how what
the question might be this is I would
really like to hear them okay so thank
you for the invitation and let me begin
with two remarks that I find very
visionary on the interaction between
geometry and criminal Toric's so the
first one is from one of my favorite
papers by a fan Goreski Mike Pearson
circa nova where they say we believe
that combinatorial methods will play an
increasing role in the future of
geometry and topology and i will be
talking later about one of the main
theorems and in this paper that i find
very beautiful and that's relevant to
this talk 1987 but a fourteen years
earlier a it actually was probably
earlier than this because it this is a
in a book that's a volume in honor of RC
both and a paper by Kelly and Rhoda they
talked about visiting both and and he
told them we combinatorial lists have
much to gain from the study of algebraic
geometry if not by its direct
applications to our field at least by
the analogies between the two subjects
and I think you see in this talk that
that a lot of what happens in this talk
is right at the interface of geometry in
combinatory sometimes the application is
direct and sometimes it's just kind of
borrowing from each other's philosophies
so I just took just to summarize the
main points that I want to make the
first point is that mate roads are
really geometric in nature yeah I would
say that metrics have different
incarnations but but in some sense I
think of them as very geometric objects
geometry and Maitre D' really help each
other a lot and I think most relevantly
to this meeting and the reason why I'm
probably why poly was invited to speak
here is that we can use tools from
geometry to prove a lot concavity
results I should mention that I'm
actually going to try to survey the work
of a number of people but but the work
of mine that I will be discussing is a
some work from actually 2003 is when we
really did it with with Carly Clemens
opera MSRI and then some some work that
we have been doing over the last couple
of years with Graham denim and joon-ha
so let me not assume that you know what
I'm a trait is so what our mayor is
about the idea of a metro it is to
capture the combinatorial essence of
Independence and there's many notions of
Independence in mathematics and and the
main one that that will be inspiring to
us here is linear independence so
imagine that you have a set of vectors
let's say spanning art Rd or some other
vector space and then you're going to
look at the at the basis of your vector
space that you can find within your
collection of vectors so for example
here I have vectors in r3 I'm going to
keep this picture here so that you can
remember it B C D and E are on the floor
a is pointing up and you want to make a
basis using them so if you want to make
a basis then you should definitely make
sure to pick a because that's the only
way you're going to leave the floor you
shouldn't pick D and E because those are
dependent from each other and as soon as
you do that you can you can pick any
other combination of three and so you
get the DS are the five basis that you
can make so this is called the may trade
of this configuration okay now there's
some very important properties
no matter what vector configuration you
start with a there's at least one basis
and and the key property that has been
helped that has appeared in several
talks in some way or another is that if
you have two basis a and B and if you
have an element of the first one that is
not in the second one then you can
replace that one by an element that's in
the second one I'm not in the first part
so that a - a union B is a basis this is
a nice exercise in linear algebra and it
motivates this definition that was
discovered at approximately the same
time by nakazawa and Whitney that if you
have a set P and a collection of subsets
of that set if they satisfy these two
properties then they're called a Maitre
D' so this
this is supposed to be some kind of
abstraction community or abstraction of
linear algebra okay now a good theory
should have lots of examples and so
let's talk about several several
examples of matrices that occur in in
mathematical nature so the first ones I
just discussed are linear matrix they
come from a vector configuration and
them are linear independence the other
very big example that motivates a lot of
this theory is a graphical matrix so
this is you start with a graph you label
the edges and then you're going to look
at the spanning trees of your graph okay
example if you want to make a spanning
tree here then it's kind of the same
situation that in order to connect to
this vertex you need to choose a and you
better not choose D and E because they
form a cycle and then any choice of
three edges that satisfy this are going
to give you a spanning tree okay and so
you're gonna find that actually the
spanning trees of of this graph are
exactly the same that I they correspond
to the basis here okay and it's a simple
exercise in graph theory that spanning
trees are also satisfied that a basis
exchange property but there's many other
examples and I think three that are very
important is one is a break independence
so that's another very natural notion of
independence and whenever you have a
field extension then if you have to
break independence of the elements of
the top and the extension over the
ground field also satisfy this axiom and
so that gives you an notion of algebraic
may trade also in any bipartite matching
problem you get it's called a
transversal may trade and in any routing
problem where you have a let's say a
directed graph and you're trying to
figure out what are the ways of getting
to some sinks what are the what are the
vertices that you can route to the sink
so that the routes don't intersect with
each other those also form a Maitre D'
okay so these are five of many other
families of metals that are important
and so the I think one of the points of
matrix theory is that once you prove it
here in four meters
you get theorems and all these steals so
it's a very nice general concept okay so
let's see so the a transversal and
transversal matrices and gammas are all
realizable as linear matrix as soon as
your field is big enough a graphical
matrix also
and then algebraic matrix a you can you
have to be careful with the field but
but yes I mean and and actually you're
anticipating the one of my next slides
which is that we should talk about how
important this is that they're
realizable or not realized okay but here
in some sense I'm only telling you one
example which is linear matrix and some
and some special cases of them okay now
before I do that let me talk about a one
thing that's important in matrix theory
is that there's many different points of
view and they're all important so for
example when when you take the bases
like I just did it's actually very
useful to make a polytope out of them
and so I drew that polytope over here so
you can see it
[Music]
I have to do some erasing in a second
but here my basis and then for each
basis I just make an indicator vector a
zero one vector so for example a b e
tells me a B are in C and D are not V is
in so I get the vector 1 1 0 0 1
hopefully I put it here somewhere so
this is the basis a B II and I do that
with my 5 bases and I get a nice politic
okay well and we'll talk more about that
politic so that's a one important model
of a may trade I think I'm gonna erase
this and I'll draw it again if I need
now another point of view that I can
take is just the point of view of the
independent sets so so let's not only
look at the basis but they're all that
all the tests that are independent so
you have it there they're all the bases
and all other subsets and it gets kind
of clumsy to a list all of them and
actually what ends up being more useful
is to draw a nice picture of a
simplicial complex and here are the
important properties that have you taken
an independent set and if you remove
things from it then you're still going
to be independent so that's why you get
a simplicial complex and so this picture
is summarizing all the independent sets
so if you see a triangle in here then
that's a basis but for example there's
no edge between D and E and that tells
you that they said de is not independent
which we knew because the any are
dependent here so when you look at the
independent sets is very nice to keep
track of them in this simplicial complex
another useful way to think about
matrices is through the circuits and
those are the minimal dependences in in
the graph this is easiest to see the
minimal the pencils are de b c d and BCE
and it turns out that is it's in some
context is useful to break them and the
way that you break them is that you take
each circuit and you remove the largest
element now of course that's only
well-defined ones you once you decide in
on an order of your ground set but I'm
just going to do it alphabetically and
so here when I read the the biggest
elements I erase a and I get D I erase
DN I get BC and I get e are you raise e
and I get B C so all my broken circuits
and there's something that you can do
that is very nice which is that what I
drew here is
the independence complex of the metroid
but now i'm going to look at the sub
complex which i'm going to call the
broken circuit complex
and what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to look at the independent sets
that do not contain a broken circuit
okay so I should not contain D and I
should not contain the edge BC so then
what I'm left with is this this bottom
triangle up here down here and this
triangle over here
so these are the and empathy independent
sets that do not contain a broken
circuit and when we want to keep track
of the broken circuits its if you
haven't seen this before it might seem a
little bit strange but it turns out that
this broken circuit complex is a very
natural way of doing it that arises in
several contexts
another point of view that is important
is flats and the flats are basically the
soft spaces that that your collection
creates the the spans of spaces so you
can see that your set spans all of our
three so that's ABCDE if you look at the
planes that are spanned it's the plane a
B the plane a de the plane AC and the
floor so that's DS and then if you look
at the lines that you that you generate
they are a b c and d e so these ones and
then just if you look at the origin it's
a soft space that is kind of spent
trivially and we want to put it in there
and so that is a collection of flats and
it turns out to be very useful to take
those flats and make them into a post-it
which is in fact a elias and i have
drawn over here so it's just a post-it
under containment
so I feel like if you're saying matrix
for the first time now then this would
seem like a lot this is like many
different ways of thinking about the
same object and when I first learned
about them I got frustrated that there
were so many different ways but when you
start working with matrices I'd actually
it is important to to look at these
different models and often they in one
model something is very clear whether
the different model is very difficult to
prove it so and I think that's the thing
that you'll see in this talk that we
actually will need all of these models
and so I'm going to keep them up I think
and I hope that this thing is not too
distracting
okay so now let's talk about la
concavity so
so one thing that a one important in
variant of a a special complex is just
counting how many faces it has in each
dimension okay so let me just write down
the F factor of the context here so what
I'm going to do is just count okay first
of all how many empty faces do I have I
have one empty face now
how many points do I have and I'm doing
this for the broken circuit compass
which is why I'm using the color blue so
then I have a four vertices the working
circuit complex the number of edges is
five and the number of triangles is 2
okay so this is what's called the add
vector of the broken circuit compass
and I could also do it for the
independence complex and I'll get
something bigger and so there was there
were these series of conjectures by
Wells Mason Rhoda Haran a Welsh later
that a this sequence the effector of the
broken circuit complex and also of the
independence complex are unimodel block
concave and strongly long concave
I think one one important remark to make
right now let me make two remarks one is
that in the way that I've defined it is
not it's not clear that this sequence is
well-defined because remember that the
broken circuit complex was given from
the broken circuits which depended on an
order of the ground set okay and
actually if you if you change you order
of the ground said you are gonna get a
different complex and it's not going to
be coming at earlier morphic in general
but it's but it's here and that is not
too difficult to show that actually the
F factor is the same okay so I think
that's one important comment to make and
another important coming to make which I
think is due to Welsh is that every
independence complex is a broken circuit
complex so if you want the independence
convinced of a metroid you just augment
by the metric by the way what I think is
called the dual the dual core extension
by a free element and when you do the
broken circuit complex with a specific
order on that bigger maitreya you get
your independence complex of the
original matrix so even though these two
a conjectures are about independence
meet independence complexes and broke a
circuit complex as it turns out that
that this is a subproblem of this one
and so we're going to focus on the
broken circuits what I mean I think what
you mean but so what I mean by well
let's let's solo concave this let's
actually write it also a unimodal
I mean that the numbers go up and then
down a lot concave
is that
I'm going to reveal that I don't think
about locking company so much that I
always forget which direction it goes
can you help me create a limb and then
strongly Longclaw concave right so we've
seen all these adjectives here strongly
la concave means that you can put
binomial coefficients here what I want
to do is and choose them by minus one
this is sometimes called ultra all
silicon Tim is that what I should have
said so
ultra low concave I wonder if I had it
right and then I was headed in my my
talk earlier today I'm seeing all these
adjutants I got might have gotten
confused but anyway what I mean what I
mean is this this this has been called
the strong most amazing conjecture which
which we will we've seen a proof this
morning actually
I believe so but you know you know you
think about this more than me so I don't
want to go and record saying that
because I'm not sure so just look it up
in the literature later because I'm not
I'm not entirely sure I should say that
you know before this week my talk used
to say this and not to strongly part but
of course we have these exciting new
developments where we put get put we can
put an ultra here okay so a well as as
many of you know and I think this is one
of the reasons that we're all here
together there's been a lot of exciting
recent progress on these problems so
it's a theorem of the pursuit of who and
cuts from 2015 disappear disappear last
year that these sequences are indeed la
concave and therefore a unimodal and to
do that they developed this hodge theory
of matrix and I should have said ultra
here so a much more recent theorem which
we heard about this morning is that they
are ultra low concave and this is done
through either the theory of completely
law concave polynomials or loretty of
polynomials which we learned are the
same thing so this is all very recent
and some nice corollaries which we've
heard about today and I think we're
going to hear about some of these cars
tomorrow also is that you can use these
results to approximate the number of
basis of a Maitre D' deterministically
and also you can prove that the old
conjecture that the expansion of the
basis exchange graph of a matrix at
least one so the strongly part only
applies to the independence okay thank
you
[Music]
let me say it to the microphone for the
people that are watching that Jun is
telling me that the that the ultra part
of the conjecture only applies to the
independence complex and not to the
broken circuit compass okay so now let
me talk about a slightly different a
quantity or invariant which is the H
vector okay and the H vector what you do
is that you say okay well let me take
this F vector I'm going to make upon a
polynomial out of it which is the
reduced characteristic polynomial
so there it is if you have thought about
these kinds of things then you will know
that this characteristic polynomial I
could have also computed in a couple of
different ways one from the from the
lattice I can compute the Mobius
function of the lattice and then a that
gives me the characteristic polynomial
of the post set which is this polynomial
the other way of doing this is that
because this is a graphical metric then
we could just count the proper coloring
of the graph and that's also given by
this polynomial so this polynomial is
actually extremely important and we're
going
so I paired this ahead of time and this
doctor says Q minus 1 squared times Q
minus 2 and so now I'm going to just
plug in Q plus 1 so I get Q squared Q
minus 1 which is Q cubed minus Q squared
and then these coefficients are going to
be what's called the H vector with the
broken circuit complex and this is the H
vector of the broken circuit complex I'm
giving you one of the possible
definitions but but there's other a
natural definitions of this for example
if you're if you're familiar with
shareability then this is what's called
the shelling polynomial of this complex
it also has some nice topological
interpretations but this is the most
direct way to define it and we have
these conductors do tube allows ki
Dawson and he be that these sequences
the H vectors of independence complexes
and of broken circuit complexes are also
in the modal on Lok concave and one
thing that I learned from you a few days
ago is that they actually don't have to
be strongly concave you see so there are
examples where they're not strongly
ultra-low conky's
I think one one remark worth making is
that the this conjecture implies the
other one so if if the H vector of a
simplicial complex is LA concave then
the F vector is strictly LA concave and
by that I mean that is LA concave with
strict inequalities okay but I actually
wanted to do this example so that so
that you can see that intuitively what
happens is that the add vector is a lot
bigger and the H vector is a very it's a
much more economical way of storing the
F vector so the I factor kind of goes
like this and these vectors actual are
smaller and so in suitable you can you
can think that that explains why it's
harder to prove a la concavity and
univer allottee for for kind of a
smaller encoding of this impact
and you mean the support as far as the
entries like the nonzero entries I
believe so but I am NOT yeah I don't
want to commit to that but what I mean
one thing that does happen is that is
that the effector is a positive
combination of the age factor so you can
definitely kind of make some some
quality quantifiable statements that
there F is bigger than H
okay that I'm not sure actually so so so
lens observed that la concavity of each
implies lock a by locking tab key of F
but I'm not sure if if you can also put
ultras there or other additives it's an
interesting question that I to be honest
I don't I doubt that anybody has has
worked this out
okay and so a maybe the theorem that I
would like to tell you a little bit
about is is that these conductors are
also true and this is the content of our
work with gram denim and and joon-ha and
and to do that we had to develop what
we're calling the Lagrangian a
Lagrangian theory of matrix so yeah so
one of the goals of my my talk is just
to tell you a little bit more about that
now let me let me just make a quick
comment why why do I care about lock
concavity we are we have our different
reasons we have our different a taste in
mathematics I was actually really
excited to see that low concavity has
specific applications where you can
prove algorithmic results about me
towards you can prove expansion results
things like this these are not the kinds
of things that I usually think about and
I was very excited to hear about them my
my take on locking cavity has has been a
little bit different you know Debray
come in a torus there's a lot of
sequences that either we can prove our
lock on cave or we think our lock on
cave or or sometimes just unimodal or
sometimes just positive and when you
observe this it's there's like a
junction on the road either the proof is
something you can do in an hour by
writing a little recursion and just seem
pretty easily why why this is true or
you're really facing a hard problem
there's not a lot of instances like this
where the problem is kind of medium you
really either it's it's fairly
straightforward or you really need
something new and when this has not been
easy a these proofs have usually
required a fundamentally new idea a new
construction and new connection this
often has to do either with some results
from intersectional theory a kind of a
kovarsky kind of inequalities
representations of the lie algebra is l2
there's usually some kind of connection
that you have to make and the way this
pose usually go is that you have to
develop a lot of new structural results
and then usually the footnote and
by the way we we can also prove this
conjecture and in some sense this is
what it would interest me the most is is
that a you know I think these are nice
conjectures to prove but but what I get
more excited about is just how much new
mathematics comes out of them ok so now
let me a let me briefly address a
question so our matrix geometric so I
said that a linear matron is one that
comes from a set of vectors now national
question is are all Maitreya and and it
turns out that they're not and then
there's things like the Phenom a Troy
the non phenom a troy'd there's farmers
matrices that you can construct there
there's weird matrice that you can
construct that are not linear now the
thing is though that this is a little
bit like with rational numbers that if I
think of a number is probably going to
be rational and yet we know that no
numbers are rational 0 % of numbers are
rational and and this is the same
situation here we're like we just don't
have that much of that much imagination
and almost any may trade that we think
of is linear because it comes from some
kind of construction that starts with a
set of vectors in some way or other but
there is a very recent theorem that
actually 100% of meters are not linear
and this has been a conjecture that has
been bothered people in kind of
structural matrix theory for decades and
it's finally settled that matrices are
just a much bigger class than linear
matrix and so one thing that I should
say is that when Maitre theory was first
getting started once it was discovered
that not every major is linear people
thought well let's try to find the axiom
that will make that will make them
linear so let's try to change the
definition of a matrix reducing the
linearity axiom they would
there are several papers about this
missing axiom but again there's a
there's some recent results from the
last 10 years that say that you really
cannot do this in you can kind of choose
what kind of a logical system you you
want to work on but but there are
statements of the form you know in in
second-order logic you cannot weigh to
send a characterization of matrix
so it's not it's not really that we're
missing access here matrons don't want
to be linear that's that's really what
it is and and the point that I want to
make is that this is not a flaw and I
want to convince you that that matrix
are already natural geometric objects
just in a study differently okay but we
should embrace the fact that most
matrices are not linear because that's
what they are this actually goes back to
this to this this fight that Jack Carlo
rode I was trying to fight many years
ago where he didn't want to call the
matrix he wanted to call them geometries
or combinatorial geometries or pre
geometries and he even wrote a book that
a call coming authorial geometries but
it didn't take people tell me you're
really talking about me trees aren't you
and I think that broad I would be very
pleased with these kind of new
developments that are showing that may
trees are really much more geometric
than then people knew at the time that
he wrote this so let me start with with
one a result along these lines
so what is one way in which matrix
really are geometric objects through
this method polytope okay so a so I told
you that if I if I start with a Metroid
I can make a polytope out of it by just
making zero one vectors that are the
indicator vectors of my basis okay I
think that conveys whole and I get a
polytope and I should say that this
construction very interestingly arose at
least twice in very different contexts
so I think the first time that this was
done was by Jack Edmonds in 1970 and and
he was doing optimization and he was
just thinking okay you know how do I
find the minimum spanning tree of a
graph and and kind of typical coming out
to optimization to do is if you wanna if
you have a set of vectors you model it
with a polytope so if you have a set of
coming at or objects that you weren't
optimize over make them into a polytope
and try to cast it as a linear
optimization problem and that's what he
did and then he he found that this was
the polytope where we should be doing
optimization for that kind of problem
and independently
your financier Canova and independently
Goreski and Macpherson discovered that a
these matrix polytopes also arise very
naturally in geometry the the paper that
I alluded to in the second page is this
one and and maybe I'll just say a couple
of words about this
if you look at the grass money on of K
planes in n space so you have an N
dimensional vector space and you're
looking at the K dimensional sub spaces
and and there is a nice way of making
that into a nice variety and there is a
natural action of the torus here and
what you can do is you can take one of
these points which represents a subspace
and see what the torus does to it and
the torus would kind of taking around
and so you can look at maybe you have a
vector space here we'll call X so you
look at how the torus acts here and you
take the closure of that and this gives
you a torque variety and then there's
something called it the moment map that
turns a torque variety into a polytope
that moment meant what you get is
exactly this metropolises for which
metroid the the matrix that you
naturally would associate to this
subspace okay so maybe you got that
maybe this is this is not familiar to
you but I think the point that I'm
trying to make is simply that in in the
geometry the grass Mannion its extremely
natural that these polytope arises
arises equally naturally an optimization
and in algebraic geometry ok now
this is one of my favorite theories and
Maitre theory it says that if you have a
bunch of a bunch of sets B and you want
to know if those sets form on a trade
then what you do is you just construct
the polytope that I just show you how to
construct and you started with a Metroid
if and only if the polytope has edges of
directions EW - EJ
so for example you can see that the
edges of this polytope if you look at
any two of them and you subtract these -
this you're gonna find you get 0 0 0 1
minus 1 this is Direction V 4 minus e 5
ok Authority it means that you're
exchanging a 4 4 a 5 in the basis and so
what this tells you is that you we can
come up with a new definition of Maitre
D' there are so many definitions that we
might as well add more to the mix a
Maitre D' is 0-1 polytope with as
directions EW - ej when I say 0
unpalatable I mean a polytope whose
coordinates are all zeros and ones the
vertices are zeros and ones
so the main point that I want to make
here is that from this geometric point
of view there's there's nothing special
about linear matrix and if you want this
equivalents to be true then you actually
have to welcome a nonlinear matrix and
so from this point of view it's very
unnatural to throw to throw them out
matrice really provide the correct level
of generality for what we're trying to
do here
okay and if you like this sort of thing
then you'll then you'll know that this
is the root system of a lie algebra of
type a and then you should immediately
start asking okay what about other root
systems and you get a really rich theory
of coxeter matrix that that shows you
that that somehow many trees really are
connected to a the root system of wide
open air condition on the edge direction
or is it a different distribution sorry
can you say 100 percent of majors are
nonlinear beautiful Oh uniform yeah so
so just if you if you let's say fix the
number of elements on the rank and you
ask how many of these Metroid's are are
representable or linear then it then
that goes to zero
in particular I'm right with Chris my
answer presentable - we get yeah that's
right so so the the points that you get
from the Gotham Goreski McPherson Sega
Nova these polytopes are all are only
the linear the polytopes of linear
matrix because they come from geometry
they come from the grassman you do that
to me and that defines the configuration
to make sure it is right yeah yeah
that's right
if you if you want to think so one way
of thinking about it is that if you have
a vector space or end and and you have a
sub sub space a K dimensional sub space
and and I need to make a meet right out
of it then you can say okay let that
subspace be the row space of some matrix
and then look at the independence of the
columns which is equivalent to what
you're saying so it's very natural as a
Maitre dissociated - okay so this I
think is the beginning of an explanation
of why I would a matrix really are
geometric in nature now the next thing
that I want to point out is that mate
with our tropical let me say what I mean
by that so here's a construction that
you can do for a Metroid we're gonna
we're gonna build a second polyhedral
model of mater it's called the Bergman
fan where what you're going to do is
you're going to start with your flats
and then for each flat you're going to
make array in that direction so for
example if I have the flat AC then I'm
going to make a ray in Direction one
zero one zero zero they indicate a
picture of AC which is right here so you
do this for all except for the top and
bottom so I have eight proper flats
which is why I have eight Ray's coming
out of the origin over here but I want
to make this into a pole into off into a
fan and the way that I do that is that I
fill in for example a the cone between a
and a B because a is contained in a B
but for example a is not contained in B
CDE and for that reason I don't put a
cone between Ray's a + b c d e that make
sense of that so the the cones that i
fill in here are precisely corresponding
to the flags of inclusions of flats so
they have a flat inside another flat
inside another third and sorry another
flat then that's going to give me a
four-dimensional a face in my program
so so in some sense this construction is
is kind of just a recasting of the
lattice of flats where I'm taking a
little address of flats and making it
polytope but it turns out that is not
just that so this realization is
actually important these Bergman fans
appear very naturally in tropical
geometry and I won't try to say a lot
about this except except to say that a
tropical geometry is a field where you
try to answer questions in algebraic
geometry by tropical icing them into
questions a polyhedral geometry so if I
have an algebraic variety V then there
is this procedure that if you're curious
I can tell you after the talk how you do
it
you turned your algebraic variety into
its tropical ization which is piecewise
linear object it's a polyhedral complex
and the really striking thing about this
is that even though this this
construction loses a lot of information
it actually keeps a lot of information
and and there's a significant amount of
problems that are very hard to do
algebra geometrically but you can
tropical eyes them then you can solve
them polyhedral E and that allows you to
do combinatorics and polyhedral geometry
and then kind of reverse it and get
algebra geometric theorem back
a question that was asked by barrister
cuts in 2002 is let's just let's just
think about a very simple example of
this so so you can topic lies any
variety and you can you get something so
what happens if we take the simplest
varieties which are which are just
linear spaces and and the theorem that
we proved with Carly Clemons is that a
if I start with a with a linear space as
a k space a case of space off R to the N
and I tropical eyes it then I get some
kind of piecewise linear object and and
what I get is precisely this fat ok so
so we didn't just come up with this
definition out of nowhere this is very
naturally the tropical ization of a
linear space ok and I think similar to
what you were saying earlier sacha so
this this construction right now a only
gives you linear matrix because I'm
starting with a saw space so when I
tropical I said I get the Bergen fan for
a for a linear matrix
but I want to make the point that I
don't want to throw out the ones that
are not coming from the near matrix and
and to make that point a let me just say
that okay so there is this theory of
tropical varieties so these are
piecewise linear objects that have this
kind of balancing condition at the
corners so maybe you've drawn you've
seen pictures like this where you have
these tridents where you should have
balancing at the corners and in
algebraic geometry if you have a variety
like a bola there's there's kind of two
main invariants that the first two
invariants of a variety are the
dimension in the degree so the
digression is the number of degrees of
freedom and the degree is so for example
how do we know that that the parabola
has degree 2 because if we intersect it
with a generic line the number of
intersection points is 2 you want to
know the the geometric degree of an
algebraic variety you just intersect
with the surface of the correct
codimension and count the intersection
points tropical geometry also has a
notion of degree which is the same thing
except now instead of intersecting with
a line I should intersect with the
tropical line which is a Birdman fan and
they're very striking thing about this
is that when you start with a with an
actual geometric variety and you
tropical eyes it the dimension and the
degree don't change so that's what's
something that that doesn't get lost
along the way ok so
now a natural question that we can ask
is okay well then what are the you know
out of all the tropical varieties what
are the ones that have degree one
because those are going to be the analog
of linear spaces and so a theorem of my
student Alex Fink is that a tropical
variety has degree one tropical degree
one in the sense of intersection theory
if and only if it is the Burgman turn of
a matrix but the thing that's striking
here is that for this Piron to be true
you have to include nonlinear matrix so
if you believe that this study of
tropical intersection theory is
worthwhile then you are stuck with
having to consider a nonlinear matrix as
part of your story okay
from this geometric viewpoint all matrix
are equally natural and matrix you
really again provides the correct level
of generality for this and this is
another sense in which may trades are
really inherently geometric and
inherently tropical you can define a
material is the tropical variety of
degree one it's that's a correct
definition okay so this is a sense in
which may trees are tropical
so this is this Bergman fan okay and and
I'll explain in a second what that what
the Bergman fan has to do with with
Locke concavity but before I do that let
me let me tell you about a second fan in
order to give tell you about the second
time I'd I need to tell you about dual
matrix so every may trade has a dual may
trade where you just take the basis of
the first matron and you take their
component and those are the basis of the
dual matron I'm always amazed by this
definition actually it's very simple I
know how to prove it but I but I find it
very beautiful and and in particular
this the simultaneously generalizes the
notion of graph duality for planar
graphs and the notion of orthogonal
components it's it's all these things
that okay they're simple but I find them
very exciting still twenty years after
learning about them so every may trade
has a dual matrix okay now let me tell
you about a new a polyhedral model of a
Maitre D' so we have the Bergman fan but
now I want to show you a similar one but
a little bit more complicated the core
normal fan of a may trade
it's a polyhedral complex in twice the
dimension so it's two copies of the
ground set one has basis II and the
other one has basis F so remember that
in in the in the Bergman fan the Rays
were of the form e sub F where I puts a
plat here
the Rays are going to be of the form e
sub F plus F sub G where F is a flat of
your original Metroid and Jesus out of
your duel may trade so what we would
call a co flat and their union has to be
the whole set okay so those are going to
be the race and if for those of you that
are used to thinking about matrices
you've seen this notion of a flat and a
co flat whose union is the whole set I
would love to hear because it's very
essential to what we're doing and it
doesn't seem to be very very studied in
yeah so I mean that in in the first in
the first day a copy of REI do the
indicator of F and in the second a copy
of REI do the indicator of G and now I
have to tell you so I told you what the
Rays are and I have to tell you which
cones to fill in and I'll just I'll just
show you it's it's complicated you fill
in so if you have a flag F that's
increasing and if like G that is
decreasing then you fill in the cone if
and only if this these properties are
satisfied we we didn't make this up out
of nowhere this is what the geometry
wants you to do and and if this is the
kind of thing that you like I'm happy to
sit with you after the talk and explain
to you the details of this there's some
criterion and it's kind of complicated
for what for what a face is you fill in
okay so the the faces of the core normal
tank correspond to by flags and the fact
is that all maximal by flags have length
n minus 2 this is a pure dimensional
dimensional object
sir so I think you know this is
something that is strange about this
which is that actually this dimension
does not depend on the rank of the
matrix in this this comes from the
motivation comes from like toric
tropical considerations and there's also
some kind of a coxeter combinatorics
that shows that this is really the
natural notion maybe a quick comment
that I'll make that's an application in
a different direction is that I just
told you that these Bergman fans are
exactly in in tropical geometry the
analog of being a linear space so beef
of being flat so when we think of
manifold manifolds are things that are
locally flat so in tropical geometry if
you want to study tropical manifolds
then they should be things that are
tropically flat in other words a
tropical manifold is something that
locally looks like a maître DS so this
is the Burgman fan and if you want to
know what a tropical manifold is then
you're supposed to take these pictures
and kind of glue them together with
charts and the kind of usual manifold
theory but the fundamental knowledge is
hard the matrix and so this this shows
you that there's a lot of work to do
with with meat weights here and and this
core normal fan is is kind of a
Lagrangian analogue of this construction
and so we expected so because Kane is
developing this theory of of tropical
Lagrangian sub manifolds and and at
least I expected that these objects
should play a natural role there but we
haven't explored that yet at least I
have it so I think these objects are
natural from a tropical point of view a
but what I want to explain to you now is
what this has to do with la concavity
okay
so let's go back to la concavity let's
say that you have a sequence of variants
maybe of am a trade and you want to put
another LA concave okay and so I'm going
to oversimplify jeunes beautiful work
but the key idea I would say is that
okay you have two linear meter them and
now you you actually want to build an
algebra geometric model of it okay
so and and that should be such that the
combinatorial invariance that you're
trying to study for your may trade
should be in some sense geometric
invariance of your object in algebraic
geometry and then you can use various
foreign symbol of inequalities coming
from algebraic geometry to derive
consequences for your numbers so a they
actually were two beautiful models for
the F vector and the H vector of the
broken circuit complex the wonderful
compactification of an arrangement and
the critical said variety of an
arrangement this one due to the
continuum purchasing this one due to bar
chanko and the F vector is can be seen
as intersection Theory here and the edge
vector can be seen as intersection
Theory here and so a what what Jun did
was to interpret it in this way and then
use theorems for classical algebra
geometry to prove la concavity results
so the wonderful news is that the
strategy works that the unfortunate news
is that this can only work if you start
with a linear major it because these
constructions start from a high-flying
arrangement which rely which requires
you to be linear and so we need a new
strategy and you know kind of this is
not historically accurate but with the
hindsight that actually may trades are
very natural tropically then you can
just try to tropical eyes this story and
instead of looking for algebra geometric
models you want to build tropical
algebra geometric models in such a way
that the number the invariance that you
care about should be some kind of
tropical geometric invariants your
objects now the problem you're going to
have is that is that you're gonna have
to invent new algebraic geometric
inequalities for these tropical objects
and I think that the bulk of the the
procedure hot cuts paper was to do that
because you need you need a tropical
version of of these classical algebra
geometric theorems and that's where
these that's where these tropical
objects fit in nicely
so if you want to interpret the F vector
and the H vector of the Birkin circuit
complex and in terms of intersection
theory in tropical geometric model then
for the F vector what you need is the
verb
and for the instructor what you need is
the core normal fan so that's that's the
that's the that's one of the motivations
for constructing these objects the good
news is that now you don't need the
major to be realizable this works for
any major
and I would say this is good news but
it's certainly a got us like new gray
hairs and I don't have hair so like
losing more hairs is that you actually
have to work a lot harder for for the
inequalities and and in two ways one in
getting that the tropical geometric
inequality is going and to the
combinatoric sis is rich and beautiful
and interesting and hard so a just very
briefly what I'll say is that the
proceed to ha and cat's a define the
Chao ring of am a Twitter of its Bourbon
fan to be basically I mean this is this
is really a definition coming from
toward geometry and I think give me
interest of time I won't go through the
details too much except to say that it's
that it's a very beautiful ring defined
combinatorially and that it doesn't come
out of nowhere I mean this is really
doing doing a tropical ecology and and
the main hard technical result that they
proved is that this behaves like the
charring of a smooth projective
algebraic variety it has what's called
what they've called the killer package
Poincare duality meaning that is greeted
and a is isomorphic to a n minus one
minus I the hard leftist theorem gives
you actual actual ways of realizing the
isomorphism between ranks I and n minus
one minus I and the Hodgman relations
give you a tools to to probe la
concavity because they they say that a
certain bilinear form is positive
definite on extra space that you can
play with so this is kind of the the
main technical ingredient that then
do I have some oh yeah this is a type of
this should be our and part two pages
later it needs to be an end yeah he says
these are arts and I think I might be
out by minus one else but I think one
one point that I want to make is that
before they prove this a is this ring
for at least from my point of view has
no right to have these beautiful
properties I think it is for me it's
very surprising that they managed to put
something like this of course there's
geometric motivation but but this is not
this the towering of its most projective
algebraic variety and actually work in
these proving this is really a technical
feat now having done that then they just
found these two simple classes they
represent hyper surfaces in the in the
tropical variety and they showed that
that when you intersect these classes
you intersect are - I copies of this
class with I copies of the other class
then you get this a factor and that
gives you through a clever use of the
Harshman hard riemann relations they're
able to prove that that the a vector is
not concave okay and one thing worth
worth pointing out here is that this
because of because of point where
duality elements of degree are are
basically just numbers and so when you
do this intersection you just get a
number very much like when i intersected
that my parabola with a line I just got
the number two for the number of
intersections so this is that kind of
computation and so a we follow a similar
philosophy in the paper with Graham
denim and joon-ha again our fan through
the core geometry has a towering and but
again this also has no right to to
behave as nicely as it does but it but
it does behave like the charring of a
smooth projective algebraic variety this
also satisfies these properties and we
also have to work hard to do it and in
fact we cannot just rely on the work
that they had done there's really new
things to be to be done here
but then we follow a similar strategy
where you know because in the realizable
case we had some kind of motivation we
we know what elements should give us the
right intersection numbers so that again
we can interpret the the H vector as
some intersection numbers and use the
same strategy to prove that this H
vector is LA concave so the philosophy
this is quite similar let me just say
again because I told you that that it's
nice to prove la concavity but it but in
my view actually what I like more is is
just that this this just gives you new
mathematics that that is very nice so
one thing that we had to prove is that I
mean I think one one big question to
think about right now is if you have a
simplicial fan when the when does it
actually have this this Taylor package
and when when does it not have it and I
mean that I don't have a great intuition
for this but well one result that we
needed and that we were able to prove is
that this property does not depend on
the subdivision of the fan so if you
have if you have a simplicial fan and
you want to know if it satisfies the
scalar package then it doesn't matter
how you cut it it only matters what the
support of that fan is okay the proof
that was pretty fun because we we have
to strengthen this this old theorem of
alexandre from 1930 and in topology so
he basically says that if you have a if
you have two simple compasses that are
actually different subdivisions of the
same support then you can get from the
first one to the second one by by
subdividing and on subdividing but we
need a strengthening of this which is
that actually we can we can do this just
by edge subdivision so if i have to
simply show fans that that have the same
support then i just have to sell divide
at the edges and i can go back and forth
to get from the first one to the second
one this is inspired by by something
called the weak factorization theorem
for toric varieties but this is a nice
technical tool that allows us to prove
this result and then the other thing
that i find really fun is that actually
it's a lot harder to prove this this
equality and this kind of thing i like a
lot to prove that the intersection
number
this a class and D class is the H vector
so now we thought that that would be the
easy part but that turned out to be also
quite hard so so we have two proofs one
is is just kind of a very long mate
right three prove that that really
required us to develop a lot of know
meteor theory and we have a proof that
is a little bit more conceptual more
geometric where we rely on this work on
turned or CSM turn Simons my first
classes of matrix
did I see thank you sure as far as my
fields and classes
I guess I'm influenced by where I'm
standing today and and this is a this is
a version of current classes for when
your your varieties are not smooth
actually this is kind of a tropical
version of CSM classes so Lopez de
mid-laner in Conan Shaw defined the
shorts mcpherson class of a metroid and
then we we find that there's a nice way
of interpreting this through our
Lagrangian fan and that allows us to do
less Metroid's and more geometry so for
this so let me thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
so we're getting the coolants by
desert-like effective bounce like a
recursive function are there effective
bounds for the classical theorem because
because if there are then we can make
effective bounds and sometimes we learn
we rely on the old truth the readers
decide the membership or you can decide
whether manifold is a sphere so yeah we
rely on the classical proof so we need
to kind of use the classical proof and
then build on top of it so our our
construction is no harder or easier than
than Alexander's construction is very
much depends on the controller structure
I think us to be cognizant small forever
class yep
if you have a so my judges representable
is is the the new ring that you define -
can it be seen as a conversation so let
me let me answer it for the other one
so so this chairing the original one
ba-leep is the hottest her ring is is
can be seen as the charring of the
wonderful compactification when it is
realizable yeah I expect that that's
also true for the for the critical size
variety but at least I haven't sat down
to prove it I mean that's how you came
up with the definition so I mean but
depends on what you mean by critical set
variety because it all depends on how
you actually compactified it to infinity
and this model actually chooses one
particular compactification just like
the wonderful model here chooses a
maximal building set because me to
choose other complications then your
ring will be look different but they're
essentially the same
[Music]
they're exactly what it is we can prove
that the things we need are in the
convent yeah
[Applause]